[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com there are some breathless
reports being published that say that
North Korean leader Kim jong-un has
agreed to meet Donald Trump at the DMZ
which is the Demilitarized Zone right at
the border between North and South Korea
on the Korean Peninsula and much like
other North Korea related news it's
being reported as if this is some major
unbelievable development but wasn't it
always sort of obvious that that's where
Kim jong-un would want to meet Donald
Trump more than likely we talked at the
very beginning of the sort of
possibility of the summit taking place
about how Kim jong-un said that he's
willing to meet with President Trump as
if it was big news North Korean leaders
have been desperate to get in the same
room as American presidents in order to
elevate their perceived status going
back a very very long time it wasn't
news and along the same lines this time
the notion that it's big news that Kim
jong-un would be willing to have the
meeting at the DMZ really isn't news and
Trump has been tweeting about this
yesterday he tweeted numerous countries
are being considered for the meeting but
would peace house / freedom house on the
border of North and South Korea be a
more representative important and
lasting site than a third-party country
just asking the other idea was Singapore
Singapore is a place that might not be
obvious why you would have the meeting
in Singapore but Singapore is a place
where the American military has a
presence but there's also a diplomatic
relationship between Singapore and North
Korea as well as a North Korean embassy
so it's one of a sort of smaller subset
of places that would meet both of those
requirements but from a logistics
perspective it's pretty logical for Kim
Jong
own to want to meet at the DMZ right it
allows his team to get set up for the
meeting without dealing with the
possible diplomatic yes we can call them
complexities of traveling around the
world to different places where the
relationship with North Korea may not be
quite so good but really it's the PR and
the propaganda value here combined with
Kim Jong Un's maybe paranoia that
someone might try to do something to him
if you went somewhere else that
immediately pointed to the DMZ is the
place where Kim jong-un would want to
meet and that's the thing about a
meeting at the DMZ because it makes it
so that whatever comes out of the
meeting
getting Donald Trump they're getting him
maybe to step over the line from south
to north korea and shake hands with kim
jong-un the propaganda value the
self-aggrandizing value of that for kim
jong hoon is absolutely huge and quite
frankly it's huge for Trump as well
right Trump would love to have video of
himself doing this going to the DMZ
stepping over the line
shaking can't hands with Kim jong-un
regardless of what actually is even
agreed to in principle at the meeting
and regardless of what actually happens
longer term which we've talked about no
matter what's agreed to at the meeting
we actually have to see what the
follow-through is because there's a long
history of talk and no real action or
not the action that we're hoping for
that would be huge for Trump as well and
not that this is my primary concern
would the Secret Service be okay with a
meeting at the DMZ I mean they like to
get in clear the entire surrounding area
from where the president will be as far
as we know it's hard to imagine came
jong-un saying Secret Service sure come
in to the North Korean side and control
access to the border area how do they
prevent for example I don't know a North
Korean sniper from having a clear view
of Trump during this meeting so
obviously there's no doubt that trying
to kill the president if you're North
Korea would be immediate suicide I'm not
saying they would do it but I'm
explaining why security concerns for
Secret Service would be significant in
terms of a meeting at the DMZ but the
fact that we're talk
about a meeting between an American
president and a North Korean leader at
the DMZ is already huge that I think is
really the most important thing we
talked yesterday how much credit does
Trump deserve we're not gonna rehash
that today and I think a lot of that
will sort of be known in retrospect but
I am actually finding to do this to be
one of the most interesting geopolitical
stories and I'm not it's not a value
judgment of Trump in a way regardless
this is going to be a fascinating month
do you think that this could get Donald
Trump the Nobel Peace Prize
trumpets they're talking about that even
the South Korean president is talking
about that it's the interesting idea to
float but I don't know we'll have to see
it's funny how trumpets are all about
America first and only our opinion
matters until South Korea now thinks
that Trump is responsible for the
progress that's been made and we know
that South Korea is one of in the in the
entire world is one of the most Pro
Trump countries and I would wait until
we have more information before jumping
in with South Korea on that I think I
would also wait on the Nobel Peace Prize
I think again it would depend on what is
Trump's actual involvement and
responsibility here which we don't know
well after the Camp David Accords Bagan
and Sadat shared the Nobel Peace Prize
Jimmy Carter didn't get it so if there's
any precedent there that you could read
from that I don't think Donald Trump
stands to be right it would be i guess i
mean kim jeong-hoon yeah jong-un with a
Nobel Peace Prize will trump do a
classic handshake power move like he's
done with others and physically pull Kim
jong-un over to the South Korean side
then all of a sudden North Korean
soldiers will grab Kim Jong Un's ankles
and pull him back into North Korean
territory that would be some great video
so the month of May is going to be crazy
I'm glad we have no vacations scheduled
in May other than Memorial Day weekend
and a three week break starting next
week so other than that we'll be here
the entire time no I'm kidding we
actually will be here and covering the
summit and everything else that comes
from it
okay let's talk a little bit about the
latest from Robert Muller and Donald
Trump we've talked about the back story
of Robert Moeller's team wanting to meet
with Donald Trump there was resistance
from Donald Trump's lawyer you had
lawyers I think is better said a variety
of lawyers each with a
slightly different opinion on this
hypothetical meeting publicly Trump said
that he would want to do it and he would
try to do it if the circumstances are
appropriate there was a sort of debate
around well would Muller be willing to
submit written questions to Trump or if
it's going to be in person maybe the
possibility of limiting the duration of
the meeting or at least limiting the
scope to only certain topics and what
was clear all along is that this was
going to be risky for Trump no matter
what restrictions were placed if there
was an in-person meeting right for for
Donald Trump to be interviewed by robert
muller or more likely investigators
working with robert muller
could be very very dangerous trump
possibly coming in with the idea that he
can just outsmart molar or molars
investigators usually investigators are
smarter than that often asking questions
that they already know the answers to to
see if there's any inconsistencies or
maybe apparent attempts to try to be
deceptive so we got this list of
questions now that robert muller would
want to ask Donald Trump and I want to
think about a couple things as we look
through the list and the New York Times
obtained this list we don't know if it's
a complete list but we know that there's
nearly 50 questions on this list we also
don't know exactly what the source was
in the sense of were these literally the
questions as stated by Trump's
investigators to Trump's lawyers or were
these notes taken by someone at the
White House up to and including Donald
Trump about the sort of general gist of
the questions and we'll get to that
Donald Trump immediately upon the
release of these questions by the New
York Times tweeting that he is not happy
with it he tweeted so disgraceful that
the questions concerning the Russian
witch-hunt
all capitalized letters because I guess
that now is considered a proper noun
were leaked to the media no questions on
collusion oh I see you have a made-up
phony crime collusion that never existed
and an investigation begun with
illegally leaked classified information
nice now even if you can't parse the
grammar there I think we can all sort of
generally understand that Trump's not
happy about the fact that these
questions are public or at least
claiming not to be happy so let's talk
out that leaking of the questions Trump
says he's mad about it New York Times
says they got the questions from someone
outside of Donald Trump's legal team but
they haven't said more about it what
appears to have happened is that
Muller's team passed along a list of
questions to Trump's team more than
likely at the request of Trump's lawyers
saying hey we want to see some of these
questions in advance
someone at the White House leaked them
now if Trump is mad at anybody he should
be mad at his own people right because
the New York Times didn't steal these
questions but it's also possible that
the leak was orchestrated by the Trump
team not as a actual leak but a planned
leak to try to deal Aegina my's the
questions ahead of time and I actually
want to go even further there's the case
to be made that maybe Trump did the
leaking himself Michael Zeldin is a CNN
legal analyst who used to work for
Robert Muller and he says that the way
the questions are written including very
very poor grammar suggests that it would
maybe have been Trump himself who took
these notes and leaked the questions I
don't have a hard time believing that in
principle I just have a hard time
imagining Trump actually taking notes
during a meeting like we know he doesn't
read anything and my guess is he also
writes very very little and I just don't
see Trump being the guy taking the notes
during the meeting will we ever know who
leaked these maybe not let's get to the
questions the questions are wide-ranging
some of them are very very specific at
the same time question what did you know
about phone calls that Michael Flynn
made with Russian ambassador Sergey kis
lyac in December of 2016
publicly we've been told Trump didn't
know about that so that would be a very
interesting question for Robert Muller
to ask Trump how was the decision made
to fire Michael Flynn On February 13
2017 relates to obstruction after the
resignations what efforts were made to
reach out to Michael Flynn about seeking
immunity or possible pardon also relates
to possible obstruction of justice what
was the purpose of your February 14th
2017 meeting with James Comey and what
was said that's an example of a question
that is open-ended but specific right
you're not asking a yes-or-no question
you're saying what was the purpose and
what was discussed and leaving it to
Donald Trump to sort of fill in the
blanks as he sees fit but you're being
very specific about which meeting you're
talking about you're not talking about
the earlier meeting with Comey you're
not talking about the phone call with
Comey you're talking about the February
14th Valentine's Day 2017 meeting with
James Comey another example question
regarding the decision to fire mr. Comey
when was it made why and who played a
role very important question in this
entire thing what did you mean when you
told Russian diplomats on May 10th 2017
but firing mr. Comey had taken the
pressure off that's the type of question
that if Trump's lawyers don't control
Trump or they get an agreement to answer
it in writing
that can lead to one of trumps word
salads that could be very very damaging
by what it sort of inadvertently exposes
so this is why it's such a risk to put
Trump in the same room what was the
purpose of your May 12th 2017 tweet this
was the tweet where Donald Trump said
James Comey better hope that there are
no tapes of our conversations very
interesting topic in this as well when
did you become aware of the Trump Tower
meeting that is a major major story
particularly now that we've heard from
the Russian lawyer Natalia vessel at
skaia we discussed yesterday that she
was actually working as a Russian
informant when is it that Donald Trump
learned about that and then also they
get to what did Trump know about the
communication between Roger stone his
associates Julian Assange or WikiLeaks
an increasingly interesting topic as
well which I asked Roger stone about by
the way when when we interviewed him on
the program I won't read the full list
we're linking to it on YouTube but the
big picture the most important elements
are as I said open-ended questions but
focused on specific conversations and
events and knowledge the other element
that I think is very interesting here is
that the questions we've seen have a
very wide set of paths right they relate
to Trump conversations with specific
Russians they include Oleg arcs that
we've discussed
they include Trump's thoughts on recusal
and possible firings and hacking in
WikiLeaks and everything in between
what would be
really great is if in a fit tomorrow
morning Trump decides to call up Fox and
Friends and starts answering some of
these questions looking to sort of slam
Moeller
but maybe boneheaded leave revealing
even more interesting answers because
that's actually been the theme of this
entire Trump Russia thing which is
self-inflicted damage had Trump never
tweeted and talked about what did or
didn't go on with Russia we would not
have anything close to the investigation
that we currently have and the the final
question that I have is is this gonna
happen right will Muller or an associate
question Trump in person there are
reports that there might be or could be
a subpoena submitted there are also
reports simultaneously that Muller might
decide to move forward without talking
to Trump altogether we don't yet know
but hopefully we will soon I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show we'll take
a quick break and be back after this the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is ross green lat ross thank you for
supporting independent media like the
david pakman show also want to say
thanks to Steve Archibald
Steve Archibald has been a david pakman
show member since 2012 thanks to our new
and long-term sustaining members you can
become a member at join pakman.com every
time I say it now I laugh about house
how long it's been that that was not the
website to sign up and it was a much
more convoluted one and then now all of
a sudden join pakman.com what could be
easier you just got to spell it right
and II don't know how to spell Pakman
you don't deserve to become a member
that's exactly right I read that on
4chan and I still believe that it's true
join pakman.com coupon code vote soon 18
and patreon patreon.com
slash david pakman show okay I wasn't
going to talk about michelle wolf and
the White House Correspondents Dinner
since we normally don't really say much
about it but the scandal around it has
made me want to have a conversation
about it and what was notable this this
year about the White House
Correspondents Dinner was that Trump
didn't attend normally the president
goes they get roasted to some degree and
they generally take it pretty well
Michelle wolf headlined the event in
Trump's absence she made jokes some were
aggressive some were less aggressive
some were very funny some were not as
funny but she's getting absolutely
crushed by conservative media and even
some on the not right like not left
wingers per se but even just sort of
some general media criticism is saying
that maybe Michelle wolf went too far
and the normal MO with these things is
the people being made fun of it's
usually the president people in the
current administration sometimes media
as well they sort of all take it in
stride right cuz it doesn't look good
when you don't and then the partisan al
analysts from the administration's party
will slam the comedian is going too far
or being too aggressive or being
insensitive or distasteful when it was
Obama you'd hear a little bit of that
from the left but mostly it was
understood that this is comedy
right it's comedy and it's comedy period
the right has absolutely lost its mind
over Michelle Wolf's jokes saying
everything from it was bullying that was
Mike Huckabee who said that - it was
cruel unfair disgusting inaccurate and
this is so funny
on so many levels first and foremost
being the same free speech warriors who
were supposedly against the trigger
warnings and the safe spaces are
effectively totally triggered by
Michelle wolf and arguing that she just
went too far and they wanted in practice
the White House Correspondents Dinner to
be a safer space for them than it was I
mean just a glaring hypocrisy but I
thought we should actually look at what
Michelle Wolf said because what really
seems to be getting to them is that
everything Michelle Michelle Wolf said
other than like the clearly sarcastic or
joking comments was true right she
opened with a joke about a porn star
having sex with Trump that happened or
at least there's every indication that
it happened she said Congress
accomplishes very little that's true
most people in the United States degree
she said that at age 32 she's 20 years
older than the age that would make Roy
Moore find her attractive more hasn't
denied to pursuing girls not that much
older than 12 right it's an edgy joke
but it's a fine joke to be making she
referred to Michael Cohen writing a
hundred and thirty thousand dollar check
to someone he did that what's the big
deal she joked about the liberal media
being turned on by the Trump Russia
collusion story that's a critique of
liberal media why would conservatives be
mad about that
she said Hillary wasn't in contact with
Michigan that's a critique of Hillary
Clinton's campaign she joked about Trump
phoning into Fox & Friends
he does phone into Fox & Friends all the
time why is that a big deal she joked
about maybe Trump isn't as rich as he
says he is well we know that that's
something that bothers Trump it's not
original material others have suggested
that she said Trump is a racist I mean
yeah that's a matter of debate but it's
not really unique or controversial at
this point to say that Trump has racist
tendencies she suggested that a Trump
impeachment might be bad because it
would
to Mike Pence who's worse I've been
saying that and many others have been
saying that for more than a year I don't
see how that's offensive she joked about
people being against abortion until
their secret mistress needs an abortion
that's a real story about many
Republicans and even some anti-choice
Democrats when it comes to abortions
only for their mistresses and not for
anybody else she joked about Republicans
having not see candidates that just
happened in Illinois that actually is a
real thing
she said Kellyanne Conway lies that's
undeniably true
she said Ivanka has done nothing as a
women's rights advocate I would agree
with that and then she got into Sarah
Huckabee Sanders and this made a lot of
people mad she joked that Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is like aunt Lydia in a
Handmaid's Tale she accused Sarah
Huckabee Sanders of constant lying she
joked about Sarah Huckabee Sanders being
a disappointment to women is this really
that bad like you would only really be
triggered by that if you recognize that
it's all completely true and then she
made a joke about Sarah Huckabee Sanders
Smokey Eye Makeup and people said well
is she starting to make fun of Sarah
Huckabee Sanders appearance give me a
break they should all be thrilled that
that's the full extent to which Sarah
Huckabee Sanders appearance was
ridiculed right and I've been very clear
I think Sarah Huckabee Sanders is
terrible for the lies that she tells but
one could if they wanted to is Trump did
too many of his opposing Republican
candidates ridicule the way they look
joked about Fox News having a problem
with predators of women I mean that that
is true that's true made some jokes
about Rachel Maddow that's not even
about the rise she said Trump is so
broke that he grabs [ __ ] looking for
loose change I mean that that relates to
news stories if this is offensive speech
to Republicans they are even more
thin-skinned than we thought and we
thought they were pretty damn
thin-skinned and I feel like if there is
legitimate criticism to make here it's
that these aren't really jokes for the
most part there were just like
observations about reality yes and I
think that's why comedians nowadays are
having such a tough time in the era of
Trump because reality is already pretty
hilarious so there's nowhere to take it
I mean you can't like lip it you can't
make it satirical you can't exaggerate
it and then they could argue that it
wasn't funny that would be a criticism
but most people don't get offensive by
things that aren't funny they just don't
laugh and then
Vonn with their lives so it appears that
what the right really hated about
Michelle wolf speech was that it
contained mostly the truth there's one
other angle here which is that because
Michelle wolf did go after corporate
media in a lot of ways corporate media
may have decided to enable Michelle
Wolf's critics to come on and slam her
because she slammed them during her
jokes that's another possible angle
which is interesting yeah it could be a
silver lining that this could take down
the White House Correspondents Dinner
they're actually talking about getting
rid of the comedy not only over this
incident but also Stephen Colbert's
roasting of george w bush yeah that
would be a great thing I think the
Correspondents Dinner is a little bit
too cozy between the media and those in
charge so well I'd like to see them get
rid of it
listen you got rid of the president this
year they can get rid of the jokes next
year what will be left I guess just like
a a dried fish dish that gets served to
everybody in the room I don't know what
else they'll have I've talked to off and
on about Jordan Peterson who's quickly
become known as a sort of stunning and
innovative intellectual by
pseudo-intellectuals and anti
intellectuals and anti sjw's and I've
basically characterized Jordan Peterson
as an anti SJW self-help equivalent to
Deepak Chopra with a hidden twist of a
Christian agenda and I'm not going to
recreate my entire criticism of
Peterson's rhetoric here but the long
and short of it is that he became known
for miss stating what Canada c16 bill
would have done with regard to
transgender pronouns he used that
notoriety to publicly promote his again
Deepak Chopra like teachings which if
you want to critique you're told you're
either miss stating Peterson's
statements or you just don't understand
what Peterson is saying and he's grown
this massive income for himself on the
basis of appealing to this anti SJW
crowd so what I want to do today is look
at a specific video that was posted on
our subreddit that goes to an example of
the Hidden Kristin a Christian agenda
that many people just don't see or know
about Jordan Peterson he recently
debated friend of the show Matt
Dillahunty who I've interviewed before
and at a certain point during the debate
Peterson makes the ridiculous claim
which is that even people who say they
are atheists actually do believe in God
deep down maybe so deep
that they don't even know it because if
they were actually atheists they
wouldn't have a moral compass and might
be mass murderers because you can't
actually have that moral compass without
accepting religion in some way maybe I'm
misunderstanding or misstating what
peterson said I'm sure his followers
will say that so let's take a look at
the video yeah I'm trying to for years I
had this thing going where people would
say oh and this is kind of what we're
getting out from different angle I would
say they would be afraid of what we
would lose if we lost religion and I
basically said demonstrate to me any
benefit oh you lose art and poetry and
drama and narrative library are there
are there no godless artists and poets
there are artists and poets who think
they're godless so we might have crossed
over into a problem area yeah I don't
actually I can't draw for crap although
I do draw during the show but one of the
individuals who came to the show the
other night handed me something that she
had spent a great deal of time drawing
she's a wonderful artist I'm very
grateful to get it and you know while I
pretend to read minds onstage I
constantly acknowledge that I can't
actually read mine so I can't tell you
whether or not she actually believes in
a God but I can tell you that I actually
don't believe in a god and I could read
yeah coach for you huh buddy act like
you do that's why you did I say I'm off
the stage no now you're making a claim
okay so I'm telling you I don't believe
there's a god and your response to that
is I really do because I have a moral
sense but my moral sense is utterly
without any appeal to a God explicitly
or implicitly the that's not so obvious
okay it's really because these are you
regard sam harris as an implicitly
valuable entity as otherwise you just
throw them off the stage and then the
question is well just exactly why is he
an implicitly valuable entity I don't
see metaphysics of that I don't think
he's implicitly valuable in the sense
and first and foremost this is a
hypothesis that is unfalsifiable right
the idea that atheists believe in God so
deep down that even they don't know it
you can't test that and therefore it is
not of any effective value what's saying
what he's saying effectively is that it
might seem like you can be a good person
and have a moral compass and not believe
in God
but in reality the reason you're a good
person is because you believe in God
even if you don't know about it and
that's what prevents you from being a
mass murderer or throwing sam harris off
of a stage how does this pass as
intellectual thought right this is an
example of the nonsense that he spews
wrapped up in being against social
justice warriors and transgender
pronouns and his audience just eats
everything up because they like the anti
sjw stuff and the the underlying belief
system and bias that's at play here is
atheists are secretly religious and
that's a really common thing among true
believers like Jordan Peterson which is
he can't really conceive of someone
having a belief system so different than
his so he finds an explanation that deep
down they must believe in God because
yeah he doesn't see them committing mass
murder or throwing people off of stages
I don't know how any so-called
non-religious skeptic type can follow
Jordan Peterson and fall for his
nonsense and I don't get how the
so-called free speech warriors fall for
it either since his entire rise to fame
was based on miss stating an issue of
free speech that c16 bill but I do want
to congratulate Jordan Peterson and I'm
not doing this sarcastically genuinely
he's laughing all that it all the way to
the bank with this stuff he has built a
fantastic business model on the basis of
appealing to these individuals and there
is a ton to be learned from Jordan
Peterson but it has nothing to be
learned about his there's it's not
actually things to be learned from his
teachings it's about how you can wrap
yourself up in this anti SJW free speech
stuff and have people accept you almost
as a god-like figure and give you their
money
yeah when his patreon account numbers
were public he was making $60,000 per
month yeah I don't
where it's that now but he also has his
new book oh yeah I'm like the speaking
tours very lucrative business model
that's really is similar to Deepak
Chopra in that way as well who also has
a very very lucrative business model and
I mentioned that earlier but he's also
similar to the preacher dudes that say
donate donate donate and then they buy
themselves a private plane with the
money not that Peterson is buying
himself a private plane but it's the
idea of those guys who will sell you a
really well wrapped up package that
makes you say I'm gonna give them the
money and then you don't even really
know in the end what you're actually
given the money for so not surprising
but a lot of people unaware of the
underlying sort of Christian dogma of
Jordan Peterson will take a break and I
will talk next to Deborah's ATS about
when markets don't work the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm joined today by Deborah sat's who's
professor of philosophy at Stanford
University she's the author of numerous
articles and several books including why
some things should not be for sale the
moral limits of markets this is a super
interesting talk topic to me Deborah and
we've talked for example about how even
a believer in so-called capitalism
generally should be able to recognize
that there are some areas of life that
are not best left to the free market for
example I think health care is under
that umbrella health care in an economic
sense does not have elastic demand
there's effectively zero demand for most
health services by most people until
they all of a sudden have a condition or
disease that requires those services and
then all of a sudden they really need
access to those services so I've made
that case economically you deal more
with the sort of morality and philosophy
of it so talk to us about how we can
sort of think about the moral limits of
markets generally so so first of all I
think some of the economic arguments
those selves have moral dimension so you
know in thinking about inefficiency
efficiency is partly a normative idea
you know why do we care about efficiency
why does it matter but a lot of the
recent markets are inefficient is when
they have third party effects that's the
case also of health care you are a bad
health can affect me like you're not
being vaccinated can affect me but we
need a moral theory to tell us which
third party effects matter or not that
said there are some markets which even
if they could be efficient in the
delivery of goods and services we still
think it's inappropriate to market those
kinds of goods the most obvious one is
slavery
nobody I think should object to slavery
because it's an inefficient system with
the idea that if it was efficient it
would be acceptable right we think that
it's simply you know these are the human
beings are not the kinds of things that
should be bought and sold and there are
other items human hearts might be
another one we don't think people should
be able to sell their hearts even if
it's the case that two people would want
to do to make an exchange
same thing with slavery even if people
wanted to sell themselves into slavery
we don't think that the state ought to
enforce those kinds of contracts and I
think that's another important point
about markets a lot of people forget
that markets are institutions that
depend on enforcement mechanisms and in
that way there really the concern of
everybody they're not just bilateral
deals between two single individuals so
there's an analysis to be made which you
sort of started to do with some of these
which relates to the the sort of way in
which the participants in the market
would be affected so slavery as an
example might be at the societal level
mathematically efficient in some way but
we would say that morally it would be
wrong to buy and sell people and dust
that shouldn't be allowed there is also
the site of externalities right so when
we talk about the most efficient
organization of fossil fuel of
procurement and refinement and
distribution which might be the most
efficient way to get fuel from the
harvester through the refiner to the
end-user but there's all sorts of
negative externalities that we should
consider when we think about whether it
should be left to operate in the free
market can you talk a little bit about
negative externalities in this context
so economists of course think a lot
about negative externalities or positive
externalities so there are a lot of
market trades where not just the you
know people making the trade or affected
but third parties the obvious example
would be you and I make
arrangement but as an effect of our
trade pollution is produced and people
who were never parties to that trade now
bear the cost of pollution so that's a
third party effect in fact in life and
in interdependent societies third party
effects are everywhere you know if you
buy a shirt from the gap that I don't
like the color of that is a third party
effect on me so we need to pick out
which kinds of third party effects are
the ones we think are important enough
to regulate or in some cases even to
prevent a market from forming and that
again is where moral theory has to come
in because it has to tell us which are
the significant third party effects
something that might look like it's just
a two-party deal can have very
significant third party effects in my
book I give a case of if you think about
child labor as a as a market which it is
in many parts of the world
it obviously has direct effects on the
participants and we think there are lots
of reasons that children are not made
better off by being able to participate
in these markets but there's also what's
called a pecuniary externality there's
an effect on other prices if you have a
widespread child labor market you also
affect the prices of adult labor and by
making adult labor therefore cheaper
because it's now in competition you
increase the labor supply it means that
families that don't want to send their
children to work are going to be under
more compulsion to do so because the
adult wages aren't that high
and that's why Oh so just to get close
this thought in some cases closing off
the market makes other options available
for people that might not have been
available had the market existed so you
can think about
wage minimum wage laws as something like
this they prevent some trades that would
be beneficial to the parties themselves
from performing there are probably some
people who want to work who will not be
able to find work once a minimum wage is
in place on the other hand there's a
third party effect of not having minimum
wage laws which is that the wages for
everybody are affected most of our
audience is in the United States and
most of the audience that is not in the
United States is in primarily what we
would call sort of Western democracies
so I'd be interested in hearing from you
I mentioned and on the program I've
often mentioned education as well as
healthcare as to areas of life that I
believe should be outside of the
so-called free market can you talk about
for the bulk of our audience what other
areas you believe should be outside of
that model as well so the way you
formulated this because it's not a sharp
inside or outside
yeah and should be clear I mean I guess
I should also further clarify which is
that I don't even see it as free-market
or the opposite of free-market but
really I'm talking about regulation
right taking sort of real life into
consideration when we decide how free of
a market it should be right so yeah I
don't like the phrase free market in the
sense that I think all markets are
social inventions that are you know
depend on there being background
property rights enforcement mechanisms
social norms of trust and so all markets
are shot through with regulation it's
just a dream that there are these
completely unregulated markets now some
markets are less regulated than other
markets sure we can talk about degrees
of regulation it's a I think an
interesting question to ask what Goods
should never be in the market no matter
how much you could regulate them and you
know again the canonical example would
be slavery
we think you know even a very regulated
slave market there's something
intrinsically objectionable about
treating human beings as if they're the
kind of objects that should be for sale
some people think you know human organs
are another example unless I would draw
less a hard line on that but I do think
that there are lots of reasons to not
have if you allow some kind of trading
there's many many reasons not to have a
traditional market with many buyers and
many sellers for different kinds of
things so take an organ mark you know
organs if you were ever going to try to
incentivize people to give up their
organs the last thing you would want
would be assisted which distributed
organs according to ability to pay you
know we think that human kidneys ought
to be distributed according to need and
so some one society we only have one
society in the world where organ markets
are legal at the moment and that's
around is a monopsony where the
government buys the organs from people
and distributes them on the basis of
need so that's a it's not inside a
market but it's not out totally outside
either there are other forms of exchange
my colleague at Stanford al Roth has
designed kind of barter markets in
organs where if I need a kidney and the
people who love me who are willing to
donate one are not compatible and you
need a kidney but you have people who
are not compatible we can engage in a
trade if people are compatible with my
people so that's not a market exactly I
mean there's no money changing hands but
it's using aspects of a market right in
order to more efficiently distribute the
kinds of organs there are and some of
these matching you know barter markets
with organs now they've gone
to almost a hundred people where they
you know have long chains of trade and
that allows an efficient dispersal of
the kind of organs they have so you know
I think in the inside-outside I don't
you know or or it something is in a
market or not I think we just have to
recognize that you know mark not all
markets are the same and some kinds of
markets raise ethical problems that
other markets don't
so organ markets raise lots of ethical
questions that an apple market doesn't
raise labor markets raise problems that
an apple market doesn't raise you
mentioned education and health care
those raised ethical problems that other
markets don't raise for example in
education we're not just you know I'm
trying to trade goods we're trying to
produce citizens and so we have a lot to
to care about the effects of our you
know distributive arrangements on the
production of human citizens in an Apple
market we're not trying to produce you
know citizen apples we're just trying to
get apples that are edible so at some
markets we know tend to have feedback
mechanisms on the things that are being
exchanged and labor markets is probably
the best example of that you know Adam
Smith worried a lot about workers who
spend their whole lives as appendages to
machines not be cut being good citizens
right and so he argued that we have to
have state the state playing an
important role in education we don't
have to worry about Apple markets
producing you know you know mindless
sheep but we do have to worry about what
how what our education system does or
what our labor system does because we're
you know there's a feedback loop between
us in the market Deborah the book is
fascinating it's called why some things
should not be for sale the moral limits
of markets we are recommending in and
linking to it for our audience we've
been speaking with the books
author Deborah SATs who teaches
philosophy at Stanford University thank
you so much for talking to me about this
and I'd love to have you back and go go
deeper in some of these percent specific
areas
thank you is great to talk to you the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
in the most coincidental of swamp
filling coincidences longtime
billionaire Trump adviser Carl Icahn who
literally looks like the evil CEO from
the mr. robot TV series has received a
convenient and lovely exemption from
having to buy federal credits for the
polluting activities of a refinery held
by CVR Energy a company that he owns and
back in August Icahn was very actively
lobbying against this law and the US
Environmental Protection Agency run of
course by none other than Scott Pruett
has granted CVR Energy a financial
hardship waiver now Carl Icahn already
had to resign because of some really
good investigative journalism that
exposed that he was involved in all
sorts of corrupt activity and not only
is Carl Icahn getting a waiver the guy's
worth more than 17 billion and his
company is getting a financial hardship
waiver now I'm gonna explain to you how
this all works but the optics of a
friend of Trump worth 17 billion getting
a waiver for financial hardship is
laughable at its face but I don't know I
guess if you believe in trickle-down
economics if you don't help the guy with
the 17 billion how is it all gonna
trickle down to everybody else right
privatize the losses I'm sorry socialize
the losses and privatize the gains I've
talked about that before right the
profits from CVR Energy don't go to
everybody but the circumstances that
they are calling a financial hardship
will be paid for by exempting the
company from having to buy federal
credits which would become part of the
government's inflows of money that
support our country and everything that
goes into it including infrastructure
this is the same Republican Party by the
way that says we should have total free
markets and the government shouldn't
pick winners and losers but wouldn't the
free market dictate here that they
shouldn't get this financial hardship
waiver and that everybody should just
have to pay for the credits well no
maybe not they're gonna bail out
specific specific companies and I think
this is where the details really matter
right these waivers aren't just
available to companies owned by Trump's
advice
the waivers are made available to all
refineries producing under 75 thousand
barrels of oil per day and just because
you qualify for a waiver you're not
guaranteed to get the waiver it just so
happens that CV R says the refinery in
question produces seventy four thousand
five hundred barrels a day the limit is
75 thousand to qualify for the waiver
they produce seventy four thousand five
hundred that is something that is
commonly done in the industry so of
course there is a foundation for this
type of waiver and the size of refinery
is one that qualifies for it but once
again they got the waiver not everybody
does and Carl Icahn is just the luckiest
guy in the world right this is the same
guy remember Pat when we did the story
about Trump steel tariffs then we found
out that just a few weeks before Carl
Icahn had started selling off massive
quantities of steel stock after not
selling any for three years amazingly
lucky that then Trump announced steel
tariffs and the stock prices on those
steel companies crashed just once again
Carl Icahn the luckiest guy in the world
he should be in Vegas gambling at this
point except it's not gambling that's
exactly the point it's not luck and it's
not gambling it is the swamp filling
cronyism that supposedly Trump said he
was gonna do away with absolutely
pathetic we've got a voicemail number
that number is two one nine two david p
you can call any time of day many people
do call at very unusual times of day
let's listen to the voicemail that came
in yesterday
especially played chess what is your
favorite opening and what is your
favorite defense to any opening yeah or
a certain type of open okay for your
time yeah so last week on audience
questions i was asked if d pakman on
chess comm is really me
and if i'm that bad at chess and the
answer to both questions was yes i play
on chess comm and my rating is not very
very good and since then you'll be
interested in this pad dozens of people
have challenged me to chess games on
chess comm and most of the people
way better than I am so I'm losing most
of those matches even though I've
accepted every single one and it's it's
gonna pull my rating down but that's
okay it's a learning experience
they probably wear that as a badge of
honor I destroyed David Pakman at chess
yes he'll destroyed him yes I've been
getting destroyed I mean it is frankly
embarrassing um but listen I'm not even
good enough to have a favorite opening I
mean when I'm white I open with the
King's pawn right that I do a King's
pawn happening if I am playing black and
white opens with King's pawn I will also
put my pawn I will I will move up my
King's pawn as well and then beyond that
I'll usually play you know kingside
Knight or a Queen side Knight that
that's usually my move or I'll back up
my pawn with the Queen's pawn depending
on what what black or white is done
depending on which side I'm playing but
I don't even I'm not even at the point
where I just literally try to make an
analysis on any individual move that's
been made I don't even have favorite
openings at this point yeah I know some
people want us to like play chess live
during the show yeah and have a segment
about that right but I would get crushed
because I know how the pieces move and I
know like the basic rules of the game
yeah but that's about it so it wouldn't
even be that entertaining I still think
that like for charity maybe it would be
interesting or as a fundraiser where we
do like each of us makes a move when X
number of patreon contributors yeah
contribute or something like that and
that would be kind of an interesting
thing and we could even set it up on
chess comm so people could follow the
game like we could link to the game and
make it a publicly available game people
could watch it I think that there's
something there I'd like that could the
audience contribute like could we both
work with different members of the
audience no no no y-you could be team
black that'd be crazy okay yeah much
we're definitely not doing that now I
like some of the ideas but then this is
where I'm sort of drawing the line we
would have to just play against each
other we wouldn't tech get advice from
the audience but there's something in
there you know I actually still I'm not
even good enough yet there will be some
times where there will be I'll be
playing against someone and they won't
be very highly rated and they'll make a
really unusual early move and I will not
be able to tell whether they're just
terrible players
or they're trying to use like an early
checkmate trap that I still am not even
able to identify and protect myself from
so sometimes when that happens I'll
actually have an easy game and easily
defeat someone other times someone will
make like a very early Queen move out to
the flanks and I will end up getting
like checkmate trapped because I don't
know how to block that's fascinating do
you think this will be your new favorite
pastime absolutely for the next six
weeks and then beyond painting or
something now I like chess I plan to
continue playing we have a great bonus
show for you today but I'm out of time
just trust me folks it's a good one
today we'll talk to you then
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]